I want to know I want to know what is
standing in our way
like people with mindsets like you that
women are too emotional women can't do
the same jobs as men and saying like
women should be able to what is stopping
you from going and starting a business I
started a business what's stopping me
right now like me personally what's
stopping you the fact that I'm 19 and
broke
okay okay but what would be different
than a man that's 19 and broke
right now probably that here if that he
has more opportunity just because he's a
man what kind of dumb question is that
that is a stupid question why I think
you're trying to make women into men and
we're not mad no we're not men we're
better than men I just told you that
women have been stopped by the glass
ceiling to be able to get to that stage
because I'm sure there's women smart
enough uh have enough money to get to
that point but men take men take credit
for for work that isn't theirs like
again what's what's what's what's
stopping us man
I'm telling you back
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Street talks so today I'm at the streets
of Carnival which is a huge Festival in
London and we're gonna ask the people do
wives go to Carnival why is modern
dating so hard and can you find your
husband at carnival so let me know what
you guys think in the comments and stay
tuned when I interview the people in
London let's get started who brings more
to the table in modern dating men or
women women men men people to the table
and 2023 men or women
and what do we bring to the table
loyalty some tell me who brings more to
the table in modern relationships men or
women I think if it's the right
relationship it's equal oh it's you well
if we had to pick one like in general
most men and most women but in what
category what subjects
um in terms of what women like and what
men like but they bring things to the
table differently I agree with you I
agree with you I think women of course I
think women bring less good for you well
I appreciate that yeah who brings more
to Modern relationships men or women no
that that that is uh
you can't generalistically say I I I'd
say it's fairly equal these days in in
today's society
you know certainly in my circles what do
women bring to relationships
um women bring
femininity
um and you think most women in 2023
bring feminine not most not most because
I mean oh do you know what for me it's
I'm still split yeah do you want to know
why because I've lived in my masculine
energy and like energy but at the same
time I'm not as strong as a man and
there's been times where I've wanted to
be in my soft era and couldn't say it's
like
if you can't do it for me I will do it
for myself but I'm not gonna lie any
real woman that understands will be like
I would like you to do that for me so
who brings more to the table
swimming though come on I've got a
portal between my legs it brings life it
brings life what do women bring to the
table
independency they don't have to rely on
no man they cook they work they have
their own house and it's the men that
always want to move in with the women do
men typically want Independent Women no
so then why do we bring that up if they
don't care about it because we can't
always rely on a man why because men are
cheats manner what men are cheats thanks
for watching guys like the video on your
way in and subscribe so are you looking
for a wife at carnival today definitely
not no chance hell no definitely not
definitely not definitely not why not I
thought that's a really question even
asking me that to be honest I feel like
like if you're trying to find a way
imagine your girl's on float whining
just for fun on everybody that walks
past everybody we've come to E
H do you think wives typically go to
Carnival it depends on what you're doing
in that Carnival I guess really
everything's a bit subjective when it
comes to Carnival it's a part of
people's culture right I know it's
associated with like things like what's
it associated with I'm new to it really
uh yeah let me know well I think you're
getting as I associate with whining and
like yeah promiscuous dancing but so
part of culture so if you had a
girlfriend would you be okay with her
going to Carnival by yourself I don't
know it depends on the goal what a girl
that wants to go to Carnival I don't
know I haven't been in that situation uh
I'll figure out when I get there but
genuinely I don't think it's a problem
she's like Caribbean that's like
obviously what she's about in the 1900s
they realize women are easily influenced
by Propaganda right so what do they do
they show us some sad story and we run
to the polls and that's a problem and I
just think women are too emotionally LED
we don't do the hard jobs in society men
do 95 of all the jobs that make
everything run and we lose money on
taxes
so we spend the most money we make less
why do you deserve an equal say when you
don't do equal work like that's like
mother right and I work full time
right but see this is the problem see
how you're reacting I I don't uh follow
any news stories at all any propaganda
nothing I form my own decision that's
funny you're proving my point because
you're reacting emotionally by bringing
it to yourself because I'm not talking
about you
because it's an emotic subject
to say that we are working like as women
as as as as women I know that my mother
right is working harder than any man
that we know in our lives okay so that's
I'm not getting emotional about it I'm
providing evidence to say I don't agree
with the reason I'm saying because
you're you're bringing up anecdotal
experience when we're talking about as a
group there's no dispute that women are
a net loss on the tax base
that all the women that have done
amazing things in history are too
emotional because women are real Hill
where is the female Elon Musk where is
the female Elon Musk is a wanker where's
the female Bill Gates
women don't have the set don't have
access to some of the same stuff men do
because of the patriarchy that is that
is not what are we not about okay wait
wait so what do we not have access to
but I just feel like there's there's
obviously a glass ceiling and there's
there's like there's things getting in
the way of there's things getting in the
way of women but coming to that stuff I
want to know I want to know what is
standing in our way
like people with mindsets like you that
women are too emotional women can't do
the same jobs as men and saying like
women should be able to why what is
stopping you from going and starting a
business I started a business what's
stopping me right now like me personally
what's stopping you the fact that I'm 19
and broke okay okay but what what would
be different than a man that's 19 and
broke
right now
probably that here if he that he has
more opportunity just because he's a man
how does he have more opportunity when
there's quotas and grants specifically
for you because you're a woman yeah but
that's that still doesn't stop bias
they're still buyers employees still
have bias either way who are they more
biased against men or women women I
would argue men I would argue that
because they're giving special treatment
to women by having quotas and special
grants women like I don't want to say
need but like because of the patriarchy
or something that
um we like is like we kind of need
because of the patriarchy that's
happened for over hundreds of years so
women are being okay so this this
patriarchy gives us child support gives
us benefits gives us alimony
there's where are the men's homeless
shelters
civilian women's shelters where are the
men's shelters
the matter and majority in prison men
commit the majority of suicide what
patriarchy
just because just bringing in those
spikes those in diminish the fact that
there is a patriarchy like all those
things are true yes like there's more
male suicide because men don't like some
men don't talk about their issues
no no it's not about that it's not about
that it's it's about women it's not
about it's not about race right now but
um
just because yeah there should be men
should have more access to stuff like
healthcare and like mental health care
and all this stuff but that still
doesn't diminish the issues that women
have just because men have these issues
doesn't mean women don't also have
issues I'm not saying women don't have
issues but we talk about women's rights
but we never hear about men's rights and
there's many rights that men don't have
they're the majority of the prison
population they're the majority of the
suicides what men are the majority of
the men sleeping on the streets women
don't sleep on the streets like that
that's a man I agree with that but I
don't think just because just because of
that women shouldn't have the right to
vote right but I I'm so what I'm
addressing now is you said that there's
this patriarchy holding us back and I
don't believe that because I would need
you to tell me what's holding us back
and a problem that we really have that
men don't have the the point of view
that you hold that women are too
emotional women can't do the same jobs
as men that is the point of view that is
holding women back our women more
emotional than men
well yeah that's a fact but it doesn't
stop us it doesn't stop it doesn't it
doesn't stop us so what I'm saying is
but yeah because we have like it's a
biological fact that we have hormonal
imbalances I'll give you an example do
you guys think that Carnival is a good
place to find a husband or a wife no no
because they're whining on everyone and
people that say whining ain't cheating
it is cheating
what about okay what about the women
that go to Carnival are they wife
materials
I would say
yes
she really wanted to keep your man happy
you should stay at home be a good girl
you should be cooking Caribbean food you
shouldn't be understood
I felt a differ you people come here to
have fun if anything you should be
trying to wipe the girls at carnival
because at least they're not in the
house boring
how old are you guys to start I'm 36.
35. you guys married single I'm single
single I'm recently single yeah what do
you bring to the table to a to a guy
that's looking to date you I don't know
and that's probably why I don't date to
be honest because I probably don't have
that much confidence in myself in dating
what do you bring I bring someone who's
quite chattily chatty bubbly quite a lot
I want to know everything about you I'm
an open book I'll tell you everything
about myself I know everything about you
I can be quite intense that's what I
bring to the table open open listen
honesty do you do you prefer traditional
relationships or a modern relationship
traditional modern no one you're like a
man to be a man yeah I don't want to
have that
um like stay at home Wi-Fi because I
have to do everything in the home and
stuff I would if he's doing what he
needs to do get in the pee bring it home
I would if we had enough to live on it
just on his way to another word what
would you give up to be with a man
nothing no nothing what about what she
said Instagram would you give it up I
don't even I don't want to use Instagram
yeah same but I'm all about the Facebook
life could a guy tell you what to do in
a relationship uh they have done in the
past but not going forward no same I'd
agree with what she said I'm like
certain that a man's not going to tell
me what to do so why would a guy be with
women that don't want to listen to him
because the Dynamics changed we're in
2023 men just don't like listening in
general well yeah so why do we say we
bring communication
I just wanted to say that everyone
should have repent and believe in the
gospel a lot of people here are living
in sin and Jesus Christ that he died for
everyone's sins here you know and it's
only through Jesus that you can reach
for through fulfillments you know what
it what do you think about Christian
dating Christian dating I mean because
are you in a Christian Church like
Evangelical like what's your I'm I'm
born again so I'm a believer of the
Bible right so I follow the Bible like
non-denominational exactly so in the
Bible in the Bible it never speaks of
dating thank you you know we're mental
courts you know no sex before marriage
do you believe that men should only
marry virgins then no really that's not
biblical
it's not biblical to wait till marriage
no it it is but you don't
just because I have sinned doesn't mean
that you shouldn't love me because of
that Jesus loved us well I think men
should only marry virgin and I'll tell
you why because when a woman sleeps
around she's got like a 20 chance of a
happy marriage she's a virgin it's an 80
chance and it affects women a lot more
than men so I just tell the man just
Mary virgin I thought the Christian guy
would agree with all the girls starred
as virgin I'll tell you some
um before I gave my life to Christ I had
sex with many women so am I is that
doesn't count you're a guy oh it counts
less it counts Less in what way it
counts less because it affects men less
than women we agree there's a difference
between a male and a female of course
and you'd agree a woman is way
worse
I mean in society yes so and you would
agree that a woman brings more baggage
than a male a female brings way more
baggage than a male horse no you
disagree no yeah do you think it's yeah
I do so it's interesting because a lot
of Christian guys go back to this
egalitarian model and I don't really get
it like do you believe like women should
obey husband well yes only if the man is
obeying Jesus who decides if he's
obeying Jesus because what I see is a
lot of Christian women use that to
manipulate the men where they get to
decide if he's obeying Jesus well the
Bible decides right the Bible decides
correct and so but like my question is
why why isn't that up to the man though
to obey Jesus yeah well the woman should
also be obeying Jesus well she should
obey the man though right but Jesus
first because Jesus is above the Mind
well correct but by default then she
obeys the man right if he's in alignment
with Jesus like um I can't remember the
exact verse but it's like obey submit to
your husband in all things do you agree
that it's a sin for women to not sleep
with their husband
that's not a sin I think it's however it
does say in the Bible that
um you
um what was the verse it was something
about
um to to fulfill each other's
um sexual urges for example so the man
may not feel tempted by other women so
in a sense the woman should fulfill his
months sexual desires however but you
know that's up to the discretion of the
to the relationship you know if you had
a life sentence right you were about to
be sentenced to prison do you want to
judge on her period
what kind of dumb question is that
is a stupid question why because I just
I don't I feel like give me a stupid
answer go ahead no I just I don't think
that um like being on your period would
affect your job in that way does being
on your period affect you at all does it
affect me it affects me physically
emotionally I can emotionally I can step
back take a look and be like it was
never that deep and and the man that
you've dated or been around would agree
that you you act exactly the same on and
off your period they can't tell any
different
I would agree yeah I mean I don't talk
to them so I can't I can't ask them but
I would agree yeah I think I would have
a hard time believing that you act
exactly the same because I don't think
most women do but I think if you're in a
professional if you're in a professional
position such as a judge I think
professionally you're able to take that
to like like step away from your
emotions as a judge you're supposed to
say I'm biased anyways and you're
supposed to and you can say yes
and you can you can step away from your
like getting too emotional about it
because you're professional and like
it's something that you've dealt with
and I think they should but I don't
think most can or do I think you're
trying to make women into men and we're
not met no we're not men we're better
than men but see see that that's
missandry right there it's funny because
if men said that about women there would
be a lot of backlash but you can openly
say that about men and this mean
patriarchy yeah because I can say I can
say that about I can say that about men
because men at the moment men are at the
top so what are women better than men
are a lot of things like what like what
better than men are
huh
then where's the female Elon Musk and
Bill Gates if we're better I just told
you that women have been stopped by the
glass ceiling to be able to get to that
stage because I'm sure there's women
smart enough uh have enough money to get
to that point but men take men take
credit for for work that isn't theirs
like I'm curious as a recruiter I think
that women have an easier time getting
hired for jobs what are you am I wrong
am I right right so I work in technology
recruitment right so which is where you
know we're screaming to have more
females and to bring that balanced at
least 50 50 or 60 40 male female right
so I had this job advertised it got like
30 applicants like I generally put out
of those for forward 10. I was forced to
I wasn't forced but because of us trying
to hit numbers I had to put all the
women through and all the men didn't
even get a look no and I I
I appreciate being honest about that no
I like I've actually been wanting to
come out and say this because I see
feminists saying oh pay Gap but you know
there's no better time
to be looking for a job if you're a
woman if you're like ethnic minority
like this is the best time
I have a question so when women
typically go into these roles do they
laugh
that's out of my um
to be fair right yes they have longevity
in their career
do they last in that job no because
there's a Headhunter that needs to hit
their female quota
to go and and and and and fill our feet
you know a role with a female so what
this end what will end up happening is
you know how we're like men get paid
more well if there's a shortage of
skills and uh the commodity of females
what happens in a market the value goes
up so that is what I'm seeing is
potentially the next steps is where
women will start getting paid more
because they're women because we need
them more to make the workforce diverse
so what I see too is I I don't see women
being as competent at this bigger as the
guys but I see them making more money
I I like that again I only look after a
small subset but like I don't feel like
feminists need to be fighting as hard
anymore for this equal pay right
um
and like it's all good to be pro-woman
and and all this stuff but like yeah
feminism and all that sort of stuff like
I think we're in a good place honestly
like you know as I said there's no
better time to be a female
in trying to get any job you want right
now do you think it because sometimes I
just wonder in a lot of the careers the
then are pushed into it's like why do
they keep pushing us to do these jobs if
we don't want to do them who's they
pushing recruiters corporations like you
know what I'm saying you said they're
giving special privilege to women and it
seems like it's because they're not
getting enough women applicants right
so what it is it's more that companies
want to appear inclusive and diverse
right okay and so by doing that you
would do all these things quantitatively
so therefore you you know for them to
prove that they're a diverse company
they need to show in their figures
50 female 50 Cent male so it's not
necessarily they're being pushed it's
more encouraged it's like you're a
female like don't think that you can't
do this stuff right yeah and and like so
a bit more of a positive spin on it so I
I would disagree with you because there
was best female business owners and
Property Owners four or five hundred
years ago like all the stuff you're
saying there's a female millionaire in
the 1800s okay but you were bringing up
Bill Gates and Elon Musk they're like
I'm sure there are definitely women
smart enough but men taking credit I'll
tell you the rich women in the world
I've studied this stuff actually so Kim
Kardashian is she as smart as Elon Musk
that's the female billionaire
a woman that sold a sex tape okay okay
just because she sold her body or
whatever that like doesn't mean she's
that doesn't mean she's smart or dumb
realistically that sex tape got her
famous do we respect your money moves
there we respect people that take the
easy way or the hard so you think
selling your body is the easy way yeah I
would say it's harder than doing you
think it's the easy way selling your
body is a lot of sex workers have been
pushed into being a sucker um because of
biases I would argue it's because
they're lazy and don't want to work at
McDonald's like the men have you worked
at McDonald's no exactly so have you
ever worked at McDonald's well I've had
a I've worked in sales before and and I
worked in copier sales and women were
too lazy to do it they would quit the
men would stick it out and the women
would just quit I don't think women are
lazy at all I think women work a lot
harder to beat the patriarchy to break
through the glass ceiling and to start
earning the same then why don't we see
women on oil rigs why don't we see women
on the construction site probably
because men are hiring bring these
people to work on these things and
probably think probably think women
aren't strong enough aren't able but
bodily able to oh no there's a lot of
quotas they get incentives so they're
looking to hire women but women don't
want to do it would you welcome on oil
rig no cause I'm a woman what kind of
dumb question is like dumb answer is
that I mean do you do you want to work
on an oil rig I would do it I don't have
an issue with it then why don't why
don't I because I'm in University right
which is easier than working on an oil
right you see a lot of men skipping
University and going into the trades
right now I wouldn't say it's easier I
would just say that that's where my path
has taken me right and women typically
pick the easy path I don't believe that
at all if a guy came to you and said I
just want you to cook clean and shut up
because no I'll cook and clean but I'm
not sure enough I've got a lot to say
but it's interesting because when we
tell men when men tell us what they want
we don't listen yeah we don't listen
to good clean I'll do that because I I
find Pride into doing that I have sat
for you they're predicting that 45 of
women are going to be single and
childless
me that's me do you think women are
going to be happy in that scenario no
I'm not yeah no I'm not I've got a child
so I'm single and with a child and not
you know not that happy but I'm okay so
it's it's interesting later I'll tell
you this later but can we finish the
dating I promise I'll get to this but
it's interesting because as women we'll
admit we're not happy single but we're
never willing to make changes to be what
the guys want no but I have done in the
past I've changed my whole personality
my whole Persona to be with someone for
10 years and it didn't work out so why
am I going to change myself for someone
if the guy's not willing to change well
don't you think those women have to make
all the compromise what compromise do
women typically do are they paying for
dates no
the little things that people don't
realize just you know making sure you're
right making sure you're good um
checking in on you and just making sure
you're well fed you're clean the little
things that women do like the same
things that men don't appreciate do you
think most women do that stuff
um I would like to think that most women
do yeah for the right guy they would
yeah do you think most women are doing
that for most I think women of my age
yeah but what about the new generation
uh the new generation hell no so I have
a question does body count matter no no
so what's your body count I don't know I
don't count
what do you think the average body count
is for a 35 year old woman
um
I don't know what the average is I say
my average I don't know I mean
so 30 by 35.
just 30 30. okay well I just see what I
see in the churches and like I I really
believe like what you're saying is I
just don't see them uh demonized male
they demonize female sin the way they
demonize male son so they'll come on
really hard on the men for cheating but
they don't come on hard for the women
for not waiting till marriage when
there's more male virgins now than
female virgin well those are two
different things we just said well I
think they're the same
well because when you look at the
evolutionary mating strategy of men it's
it's typically sleep with as many women
as possible the woman's mating strategy
is get the highest quality guy right and
you come to an agreement where the woman
says I'm not going to look for other men
I'm not going to try to do better and
the man says
um I'm not going to sleep with all these
women and like try to spread my seed
that's usually when it's a fair contract
but what I see in the church is them
pushing men to take unfair deals where
it's not really fair to a guy that he's
got to be faithful for a lifetime but
when she was at her sexual Market Peak
she's not faithful to him because young
women have way more Choice sexually than
young men
yeah that's true in regards to the women
having more choice but what you just
done was you're speaking about
um we're not primates no more we we
we're not meant to live as predators and
beasts you know so
forgiveness is important we're meant to
be merciful and forgive each other
forever yeah correct and I totally agree
with you but I I think God forgives you
men don't have to no we have to no no
I'm saying like men don't have to accept
that in a why you don't have to accept
anybody as a wife but right so why
wouldn't the church encourage men to
marry virgins because what about the the
because we've all made mistakes you
can't condemn somebody for a mistake
that they've made that's basically
you're saying if you're not a virgin
you're not allowed here it's not
condemning it's not they could still go
to church but I think I think marriage
is better when the woman's a virgin and
so I don't know why the church doesn't
push that they always push like the
Forgiveness which maybe makes women feel
better but in my opinion that's why
there's so many single women in the
churches is because the men have just
kind of had enough and they're the
quality of the women in church isn't
typically higher than out of church
you yeah I think I think if it was then
we wouldn't have sayings like the church
women like and I interview hundreds of
people that I think if the quality was
higher they would have a better
reputation and that's not what we see I
think the women in the church are the
best women you can find in the world I
think if they're virgin
I don't think that matters you know um
yeah sorry continue yeah I think if
because if they're really true to their
faith they would have stuck to it but
women just conveniently find God when
they want a husband I don't really
believe it I mean those are two
different things the like me I became a
Christian last year right and many women
find God they find Christianity later on
of course there's a small there's a
minority of women who they they end up
ruining their life and they're like okay
God I'm coming back to you that's not
the majority if I have a question are
the majority of women in church virgins
I wouldn't know that I would need that
actually from my experience
um
I would say it's 50 50 from my
experience and and in my experience I
would just say like I think the church
bails out women a lot and tells them
they can do whatever and still have a
husband I think they should push women
or men to only marry virgins but then
that would be going away from the Bible
right so no it's not it is completely
away from the Bible to not marry of like
you're are you arguing the Bible says
marry a non-virgin over a virgin it
isn't need to because it says um in the
Bible
um if you do not forgive those God will
not forgive you so but there's how can
God forgive me when I'm not even
forgiving I'll give you an example all
right you know my guy blessing over
there
he maybe gets a criminal record right
and then after the criminal record he
asks me on a date I can I can forgive
him and say you know you stole now you
don't steal I forgive you but I don't
have to accept that and I think we're
getting into a tricky place when Church
guys are arguing that men need to accept
that in a way I don't think we need to I
would never push that unique you just
said that before you said if we don't
forgive if we don't accept that from the
women we're not forgiving well okay I'll
clarify so I would say you need to like
you need to still accept them for who
they are but you don't just cause I
forgive you doesn't mean I have to marry
you correct and so that's why we should
say Mary The Virgins everyone else is
I don't know seriously seriously right
right because in history a hundred years
ago 85 percent of women were virgins
because the man said we are only
marrying virgins women act a lot better
when men demand more can I flip the
table you are you a virgin no I don't
deserve marriage do you really believe
that I really do I think that marriage
is between two two virgins so are you
married I think no I'm not and I think I
I really do think there's consequences
for decisions and I I think the problem
we have in society every problem we have
in society is linked to multiple sexual
partners for women
every problem homeless is linked to
single mothers single mothers tend to be
yup yup more likely than not
they have multiple sexual partners the
more sexual partners a woman has the
more likely she's to divorce the more
likely that's true and the more and once
she divorces what happens the kids pay
so that's why I think the churches need
to step in and demand virginity and then
they screw screw all the older I'll take
one for the team for the betterment of
society okay screw all the older
non-virgin chicks leave them we made our
bed lie in it okay now I think then the
younger women will say oh they the men
aren't marrying them maybe I should act
different and boom all of society's
problems are solved
or the mothers could just train their
daughters in the way they ought to be
they would but they don't know it
because they're the mothers oh
yeah the single mothers christian
mothers
from wake up and pray and read the
gospel a lot of them oh they oh a lot of
them oh yeah oh yeah there's an app oh
yeah look at looking blessing told me
that story the other day in his church
you know what I'm talking about
Christian women oh yeah they have a
horrible reputation I think no she
doesn't look that's why it says women
shouldn't
but like if you think that's like if you
think women shouldn't that's a lot of
our rights being taken away is it not no
because women have always had power in
society even before they had the right
to vote I think if we want the right to
vote we should do equal work so pay the
majority of the taxes do the do equally
the hard jobs and women want all the
freedom but none of the responsibility
that comes with it we just wanna we live
life on easy mode so we just want to
keep I don't think I don't think that's
true I think I think women struggle just
as much as men do you think a woman so
one of the number one I think no but I
think the struggles are different yeah
but we struggle just the same so you
think a secretary is struggling just as
much as a coal miner you think those are
equal struggles but a secretary could be
a man and a coal miner could also be a
woman like they could be they're both
women are the majority of secretaries
men are the majority of coal miners and
I could do 10 different examples that
are really similar okay plumber
electrician construction worker garbage
man all men
women's on top it's like teaching it's
um assistance HR admin that's those are
the female dominated Fields so if women
really could do the hard jobs I just
would like to see them do them women can
do the hard jobs they can do them then
I'll interview you next but women can't
do the whole job it's just a matter of
having choices where they just don't
want to do we have more choice now or
less Choice than a hundred years ago
more Choice Okay so
because we had we got the right to vote
okay okay so then why don't we see women
rushing into these fields since we've
been able to do them for a hundred years
because we have the choice the freedom
to do to choose what we want to do what
do we choose we choose whatever we want
to choose the easy route it's not
necessarily the easy route it's just
like are we really gonna argue a coal
miner and an assistant are equally easy
no they're not I think they're obviously
being a coal miner is harder but like we
have the choice because because we are
women and because we've got the right to
vote but taking that away doesn't mean
if we if you take away the right to vote
that doesn't mean necessarily mean we're
gonna go into those hard working jobs I
don't think we will which is why I don't
think we should
uh you want to know about this yeah I I
don't believe in freedom without
responsibility so I think if we're going
to be free we should have the
responsibility that comes with it so I
think it we have to think about and you
have to go Bare Bones here right and
modern society doesn't allow us to think
like this but we have to look at what
makes the country run all of the hard
jobs so building the buildings driving
the buses driving the trucks you'd agree
all that stuff makes the country run and
then we'd also agree that money makes
the country run right well women so
right and so my my thing is if if women
are losing money on taxes meaning we
spend more than we make and on top of
that we're we're not doing any of the
hard jobs we're not doing building the
road hotjobs time why aren't we doing
the hotel you know I know how women that
all during the whole okay so what the
media does and they really brainwash us
to believe that women do the hard jobs
but if you look at the makeup we really
don't in terms of emphasis structure
jobs one out of every two men that you
see does a job that runs Society on the
other hand it's like six percent of
women
yeah she's anti-feminist yeah no I'd say
but most of the guys here they're not
running the world
it's like most of the guys here like
come on they're not running
what are we recording I'll give you I'll
give you an example these two guys right
there they're protecting me now that's a
hard job not from us yeah
my opinions for 10 years right and I did
everything for him and then and then it
ended like that because and then so like
and I'll tell you I just think feminism
lies to us because it'll tell you to be
bitter I mean and do and do something
cool The World Isn't equal right men do
run the world right um I get that
um especially white men run the world
that is true it's always white men at
the top but you just gotta deal with
what it is and just do it by doing it
yeah I think women run the world and I
think the the whole world well men do
that well well I'll tell you I'll tell
you my my I think men do all the hard
jobs but women have the most influence
right now I would I don't know if I
agree with that I think men still have
the influence but I think women do the
whole job so they do the hard jobs that
no one sees oh gosh it's like what like
why just behind every good man is is
brand every strong man is even stronger
woman no I don't agree with it so is
there a strong man in power that hasn't
had a good woman behind him no I mean
usually good women I mean how many of
them get divorced and their wife takes
half I mean strong she wouldn't need his
money it's not about money I don't know
it's about it's about um encouraging
someone to to do well and strive and do
better I'll give you anything to do pick
up your man they should I agree with you
they should but we don't pick up you as
well to strive to do whatever you want
to do I I I think if we did that I would
agree with you but we really don't I
just feel like you're American it's
different over here in the UK I've
interviewed different the minute I've
interviewed hundreds of men and women in
the UK it's very much the same you guys
think you're different what I don't know
I'm recording it's trash I they're
exactly like UK dudes
the UK men dress
slightly better question how old are you
guys how old are you guys so I'm just
curious because you guys are you're a
little younger than me how many how many
men has the average girl slept with at
your age
five five yeah five five and you'd say
eight I say eight eight I know we're not
talking about you guys just like good
they're good yeah they're good but not
everyone is like that that's what you
have to remember not everyone is like
that when you're put in a position
find us have your fun like it's fine as
long as you'll be insane the account
doesn't really matter to me yeah so if
it doesn't matter would you say your
body count yeah
yes yes
three three okay you stand on it because
after half the time girls won't say it
yeah
I think so half of 45 percent of men
have infrastructure jobs that means they
they drive the trucks they they build
the buildings they pave the roads they
security here they do all of the
infrastructure hard jobs right only five
percent of women six percent of women do
the hard jobs and the infrastructure
jobs and let's be honest female police
officers are like two percent and a
female police officer isn't really going
to help you but I think that's I I
personally I think that's a lot to do
with a lot of men like hiring hiring
with these hiring doing the hiring
process not thinking women are bodily
able to do all of this stuff and you say
about these quotas and these grants it
doesn't stop biases they're still going
to be biases they're still at the end of
the day they're still men they're still
most likely men hiring all these all the
workers so they're more likely to hire
who they who they think will be bodily
able and they don't think women will
broadly able but women are able well I
think if we were able then we'd do it
and I I disagree with you I disagree
with you if no we don't we're it's like
98 99 men on the coal miners plumbers
electricians all those jobs 90 plus
percent men so we're not doing the hard
jobs
I disagree with you that I just I
disagree I disagree with you on on the
men that um that the men are hiring and
that's why because then we wouldn't have
quotas the men gave us quotas and yet we
still won't do the hard job the men gave
the quotas so that it would look
unbiased at the end of the day they're
still biased they're still I can there's
biases like psychologically thrown into
our brains from above you think you want
to be a victim a victim yeah I think
women want to be victim
victims of what this oppression is it's
not oppression it exists I I disagree
because I I've been able to do
everything I wanted easy I think most
women are just lazy and we see that
because most women are fat now what yeah
what has that got to do with anything
well it's a lack of discipline that's
for sure
lack of discipline yeah I would say
thinner people are more disciplined and
shape people more disciplined women that
are fatter or less disciplined that is
no we're talking about I don't I
completely disagree with it I see where
you're coming from on some points but I
completely disagree with that point
that's all right we can agree to
disagree yes I'm just waiting for
anything women are better at and
anything sir for the millionth time for
the no no this is me and okay but yeah I
just want anything women are better at
problems problem solving multitasking
then why don't they solve then why don't
we solve The World's problems the men
are solving the world's problems in it
because men don't let us
again what's what's what's what's
stopping us man
I'm telling you man they don't men
why again we're going back to the quotas
there's quotas for us we just don't take
them
because I I just think I think men have
control over most things and Men is like
the men thinking that we're able and
mindsets like yours who think we're not
able what do you think the companies
cater to men or women what companies
corporations who do they cater to
I don't know women
eighty percent of consumer buying
decisions are made by women women are
the majority of Voters the entire system
is Catered towards women that's because
100 years ago it wasn't no no actually
women always had more power in society
than men typically I feel like we're
going around in circles all right
nothing more to add all right well thank
you very much why does your shot say
woman oh I just think we got better
stuff to do why don't we vote
women shouldn't babies what depends on
what you mean by that I don't think we
should be able to I think they should
take it away I'll I'll give you I'll
give you an example so see it's like an
hour conversation but I'll explain it to
you in the 1900s women where we operate
with our emotions first right there's a
reason why every fashion trend like
women jump onto like they convince us to
get holes in our shirts puffy sleeves
what they realized what they realized in
the 1900s was they could influence the
population by showing women a sad story
and we run to the polls yeah I just
think that two bucks and I think like
like men pay the majority of the taxes
they do all the hard jobs
because currently men you couldn't agree
men like all have the most power right
now do you agree no I think women have
more power than that the world right now
they're made for women
I used to yeah in this generation yeah
I'll give you okay okay so you men have
the most yeah so I'm gonna tell you why
I disagree with that I used to think
like you so I understand why you think
that way but right now women we we pay
the minority of the taxes so men are
paying for everything and then on top of
that we're not doing any of the hard
jobs so man man and then while we're not
Housewives but we don't have we don't
have that so and then on on top of that
men are discriminated against in family
court so so they have no access to their
kids right now and I think that's and
they also um it's really easy to falsely
accuse men of
and so if you go into a college campus
there's courses that say if two people
are drunk and have sex the the woman
couldn't consent but the man could yeah
yeah and so I just I think a lot of the
laws are unfair thank you and I think
the reason they're unfair is because we
can vote Yes
say a lot majority of the people well
needed right now are men or women so
I'll tell you I'll I'll break that down
the thing about the world leaders being
they are men but they cater to women
because when Paul I've talked to the
politicians about this they cannot win
elections without the female vote
because we're the majority of the
population so so all of the politicians
are making laws for women and not men
and that that's why I think women have
more power because they can't win
elections without the women voting yes
certain circumstances like there's many
circumstances where a woman could walk
into a room and a man is still going to
be more valued I'm not saying that women
are not powerful but it depends on the
situation I wouldn't say overall I
actually I disagree and I think women
are given a privilege because they're
beautiful yeah
if you don't fit that social standard of
a woman as many women at Society
wouldn't view out most most and the
thing is you guys are young so you don't
really realize it yet but like the world
treats you better just as a young woman
because you're young and pretty you
don't even have to you don't even you
don't you find a good man with money
you're going to stay at the table you
don't even have you don't even have to
be that pretty you just have to be young
and like in shape
and the men will pay for everything
exactly so that's that's why I don't
think we should and it's funny because
when women get into Power we're actually
evil with it we're more likely to wage
war we're more likely to have
so they teach you the history wrong
actually it's it's incorrect because
it's incorrect so when when women have
gotten into power when women
when women have gotten into power in the
last so what they did was they took
women leaders the last 500 years right
and they wanted to see who waged more
and more men or women when women get
into Power we're much more likely to
wage war and I think it's because we
don't have a cost because we don't have
to fight so it's like and we get our
periods we're like oh my God I got my
period let's go to war and you can look
at this in normal life because look at
look at frat houses versus sorority
houses sorority hate each other
frat brothers are brothers for life
I agree man